hello and welcome to this video of the
round recap video for Round four of Tata
Steel 2016 a little bit later than the
earlier videos but I couldn't do it any
quicker no chance at all so here we go
um yeah that wasn't an interesting round
actually with down some action and I'm
going to cover our 23 games quite
quickly because I feel if I stretch
those too long then we would have
difficulties at with looking at the
others so I'm going to start with cards
and mamedyarov and gas starting with
that game already hidden said it wasn't
very exciting so let's see what happened
yeah that was the opening the fianchetto
goon felt and cars vent for Queen a form
yeah and this line we have seen before
in this tournament and this was in the
game I think alien of against via if i'm
not mistaken and in that game a six was
played hint it happen in this game as
well yeah and the funny thing is she
compare those two games they are exactly
identical up to this point and what i
don't get is and as it often happens
with cars preparation why is he
repeating that line from an earlier game
that gave wide absolutely nothing at
least that was my take on it probably
maybe wrong maybe he felt that white has
a load something but now he also spent
like 15 minutes and we don't we didn't
if we don't count the increment yeah
even 25 minutes on reaching the position
so what is the point i don't quite get
it and what Mammadyarov here does he
does exactly the same thing he just
repeats the game by bayi with bishop age
6 which I beg then also called out as a
good idea to avoid trading dark squared
bishop and I mean the games follow quite
similar patterns
White has taken on f6 but what is the
white idea I don't get it yeah because
blacks play is super simple he defends
the smoking so a queen side weaknesses
that he has and I don't really don't
really see what white has okay I
understand that cousin has won tons of
games from nothing positions but and
it's just like a strong game here they
do with the almost a perpetual from the
black side so um a little bit strange
repeating an opening of an earlier the
game that promised white close to
nothing spending time by doing so
sometimes it's mysterious what he's
doing um yeah in any case a draw which
is also a little bit disappointing made
from web psychological point of us
Mammadyarov in round three the round
before that had this big blunder yeah
against turn against the alien off when
he was completely winning and then
blundered a look in one move yeah you
certainly want to put pressure on the
guy who's probably am somewhat
psychologically shaken but anyway didn't
happen that was not very exciting so
after four rounds and we've got a rest
day on on the Wednesday Carson has four
drawers and wasn't really close to to
winning any of the games as far as I
remember so we're not a very inspiring
performance so far from the world
champion and next game is Wesley so ding
Liren that we're going to have a look at
until we get this kind of semi Slav here
with v3 Bishop e2 that was seen earlier
in a game in this event let me think
about it we had that earlier
I'm afraid to remember that we had that
in the event earlier I think I'm video
on the black side yeah anyway we had to
this line now with 9 35 we had a game
with Queenie too I know that was guilty
right there was a Giri game Giri with
white against someone yeah sorry I
should have looked that up but well it's
not the most critical question anyway to
be perfectly honest 95-year vessel is a
bit more interesting i believe then
Queenie too they are boasting that
neither p.m. but with a quick c5 now
black initiated simplifications in the
center and the way it went we got a
typical center out of some Queens gambit
swear d oops c'mon CND father almost got
it right here on the sea far where those
are opened and the main difference
between the two sides is that quite
often in that symmetrical structure
white has a little bit more active
pieces and he has some advantages with
his Queen the Queen often has a good
square for watching only two while black
it is slightly cramped and does not have
a good square for his queen what black
usually wants to do is to simplify and
we saw some of that he would be five
he's fighting against the c-4 night 86
and now we got simplifications coming
looks traded on the C file and now also
after the trades it's more likely that
the black queen will get some good
square the way it happens black got an
isolated pawn this but as i said earlier
in one of the one of the videos on bike
very often the weakness of that pawn
that's largely overestimated the amateur
players here black doesn't have a big
problem at all yeah he doesn't have a
bad piece in addition to the pawn and he
can pretty easily defend it it's a not
very attractive for black he will never
probably win the game ever but it's also
not a big problem yeah like this so now
if white would have taken he didn't
white would have taken then there is
some room to the eighth yeah and yeah he
white has to give up the Queen and this
is no winning attempt at all so Luke see
one was tried and that porn can be very
easily defended is attacked once by the
White Queen can be defended by the black
queen and like Justin yeah basically
stays that has no problems with d4 he
managed to get rid of the porn his name
but he had you write a check okay we had
a couple of chicks here and then then a
draw um there is no way by the way for
white to play for witness in this
position white goes for g3 there is
screen to deform and this is hanging and
if you if you cover it there are check
further checks so why is not escaping
any of those attacks yeah not very
exciting game but correct game by both
sides as it sometimes happens and a draw
was the result um next game we want to
check is Adams against ye and Adams
usually a 1 e 4 player is going for C
for him he had done this is done this
earlier it seems that is branching out a
little bit not just playing e4 and we
get many of those some slowish english
openings nowadays and this is this is
one of them yeah via here with e6 this
is um not sure if you call it the main
line now I think I think you don't you
cannot do that you cannot call the main
line as Black has many moves that have
about of equal value d65 Knight f6
everything is possible here and it's a
very flexible position for black but he
60 is enjoying a very solid reputation
back from the days when Fisher used it
to win very nice games against Petrosian
Smith's love in the early 1970s um yeah
h4 by by Adams this idea is a relatively
recent addition to white sir tries
against it and we see that ye reacts
very precisely he gets in d5 and plays
in the center that position by the way
it could have been easily anticipated by
Adams because where he had this on the
board only a couple of month earlier in
a tournament in China and maybe one day
I'll find my notes no idea yet is in a
tournament in China against a person
called sing I don't know that note
player but they followed that game for
quite a bit and so check we see that
both sides were playing quite quickly
and I think all those moves make fair
and more sense and up to this point we
were following that game Zen mod sang
against ye um ya hear Valley castled in
the in the game of fruit out of from
2015 and he is playing a new move here
with Bishop to be seven yeah the
interesting question about this position
is on what about this age six pawn is
that strong or is that week the knight
on d5 is always putting some pressure on
the h7 pawn and this is something that
is quite annoying for black yes to deal
with that on the other hand that
pollinate six might just be attacked in
them in the game um
we see this and black is yeah sometimes
ready for that jump so Adams decided to
take the pawn yeah and now I think it
gets the next couple of moves it it
turns out that the other trade was also
quite logical King stays in the center
it turns out that the porn on age six
seems to be more weakness than a
strength now we see further trades and
now it is attacked and the black king is
ready to approach the pawn so what
happened is that ye after check some
further moves was able to win the pawn
however that um pawn that is God now
it's something like that now the f6 porn
or their five porn so the extra point is
of not much value what what the extra
porn does is can control a couple of
squares but other than that the
situation is still very very solid for
white and it actually does not surprise
me that Adams ultimately managed to hold
that position rather comfortably we can
look a little bit him how it continued
the energy three pawns this week but why
does having some counter play against
the f5 porn this pawn is not easily
defended by the King as we see and the
night somehow has to stay on the six to
keep that porn so it's not at all easy
to black to make any any sort of
progress so we had some members of
Justin but ultimately that attack on the
fif porn that white was always
establishing until they agree to draw a
man managed it was enough for y2 to get
a pretty pretty easy draw even though
it's a pawn down
so not the most exciting game but again
very precisely played um yeah Adams try
to maybe surprised by E with his choice
of opening with this this kind of thing
but he had played it earlier ye and was
ready for that for that kind of that
kind of game so this brother let's say
less interesting games and now we come
to to see the a little bit more exciting
ones um we had um the game Giri kawana
in this round and it's it's a very
important game we have two of the most
promising let's say candidates forum for
challenging the world champion in the in
the upcoming cycle and they had a very
different tournament up to now gearing
lost in the first round again West
against Wesley so and easily could have
lost again in around three against David
navara if Navarro placer correct move on
move 40 on at some point earlier then
Giri will probably lose this while
kawana is on plus two and having an
excellent event so far let's see what
happened here he plays 1.e4 he plays all
openings so we cannot really say it's a
surprise but we get an roi lopez and
Cara wanna place the open variation of
their way this is a pretty rare guest
nowadays and top-level Grandmaster
practice um is there a particular reason
for that um yeah it's probably a little
bit less reliable than some of the other
lines but especially in as a surprise
weapon it's probably not a bad choice at
all yeah last time I checked this is a
while ago there were some lines where
black is yeah not having much fun in
some in some slightly was end games of
white is doing
right but it's not likely that in case
of a surprise the white player will play
so super precisely so why not deform b5
and d5 this is the way it continues the
main issue for black in the open
variation is that he's got active pieces
not only for in particular is quite nice
and he will get an easy piece play like
Bishop can kick him out to see five or
three seven castles quickly everything's
good but what is not so good is that the
queenside him that that dead [ __ ] um
skeleton of pawns there is quite weak
ard 5v5 after some a form and sometimes
a c5 porn I give you very quickly played
Bishop e3 I think one reason for playing
so quickly he has to not give the
impression that you were surprised and
in fact he's playing this as I said
quickly but um this doesn't seem to be a
very critical line I think caruana and
had a very decent position here with c5
got this and now Aguirre decided to
capture that pawn yeah how does that
work isn't room d8 good yeah this is one
was plate but why it has a trick up his
sleeve with c4 so nice little idea
otherwise it would be a pretty awful pin
but the idea is now that this is a text
and currently the bishop is protected
after Knight takes white hedges
intermedia check and saves his piece
here kawana played king of eight after
long thought a very interesting move a
much sharper move then Bishop d7 which
was possible yeah after that white
probably will capture and play this
position where I think that black has no
problems whatsoever but it is also not
as challenging as the king of a to move
that car
plate now it got very sharp Queen to c3
before and black now plays age six and
g5 to get the king um yeah get the King
to g7 and connect rooks you can ask why
is that sharpen the thing is with h6 and
g5 many additional ideas come into the
position black might go g4 to undermine
the e5 pawn what he making time on that
Bishop 126 that is slightly stranded
yeah it's not so connected to whites are
me this is much sharper than playing
Bishop d7 and allow the trades the whole
game was really sharp and played um very
well but by both sides actually they
handled the complications on very well
um after this Queen a5 move I'm black by
the way he could have taken d5 that was
an option but after you could be seven
White's initiative gets very very strong
drag in this kind of situation for
example has a hard time to UM keep that
pawn I mean you can try but let's say
you go here rookie one Queen to f6 a
quitter six still gives it away it's
hard to keep it it's really hard to keep
it on there some other way to keep it
Queen to a5 you can try a bit like a
lucky one it's very dangerous the
combination of let's say queen here to
attack Luke chicks is six sometimes
bishop age five it's very risky to take
many many attacking options this is the
wiser choice to into a five Brooke to be
seven and now eh move that is in fact
the only move it's quite interesting
White's idea of sacrificing is very
strong and black has to play rook GA to
to cover that yeah what is why it's
supposed to do now about the a3 pawn
very tricky business he decided to play
rugby three
this is actually inviting a sacrifice 96
kawana yeah if chemical can we saw cause
the bluff it's not a real of love
because white ass has enough
compensation for the exchange he took on
the night and gave away his rook their
own be three but White's compensation is
very strong it's got the d6 pawn and
that pawn is limiting black skin with
the King cannot move now at the moment
ok to e8 but that doesn't make any sense
and which means that as long as the King
cannot somehow on Gary position itself
the rukon g8 is out of the game so black
suffer serious coordination problems the
Kara wanna place that very well placed
Queen to be five twin f6 and queen a
four amazing movie account attacking the
rook with a check but he lets this rook
ya up for up for the taking very very
sharp very sharp plane um yeah now give
you a plate look to be one we can look
at the alternative slow but if white
takes King g7 his queen is hanging and
this is made on d1 so here white loses
directly this isn't working at all you
can take here and check and play this
position something that will be one
route d6 between 87 is very dangerous
for black because if you play rook to f8
white retains a strong attack with moves
like tweenage 5 for example to play 90 x
g5 it's just an exchange and legs king
is very unsafe I'm unclear very unclear
situation the move rupee one Bagheera is
also quite playable we come to a
critical position a little bit later
that Bishop was taken and now white can
take on the a to return to be 60 we have
yeah like gave the
change back but he managed to get in G
form and now the night is hanging what
is why it's supposed to do it seems that
the best continuation here is going to
be to check king age 7 and 92 after this
Ruby one and white has this idea and
it's remarkable that black can actually
take there yeah just take the pawn and
ignore this thing because there is rook
b8 pretty remarkable line now if widen
our checks black just goes to g6 and
will actually win because white has huge
problems now to find a good square for
the Queen if you go here is root b3 and
it gets worse and worse so this happened
instead I'm sorry I didn't didn't show
the line Internet's check completeness
this and is this rookie one 494 Queen
takes and takes and Hicks Quincy to has
to still be checked because that looks
kind of dramatic denying either takes
the Queen but black has Bishop and five
which is pretty remarkable yeah using
using a pin of course this is heavily
supported by the engine this kind of
line but I just just important to
understand that this is the best that
probably was possible for white at that
point and this end game certainly
somewhat worse for him yeah he probably
should lose with them with with them
very precise play but it's not much fun
he played this however and after that
he's in trouble in in real trouble check
the sea point is very dangerous
and here it seems Roxy one was a little
bit tougher than the move 94 that was
played but also 94 wasn't a rook see one
wasn't very great white is a pawn down
but I think he has more hopes to save in
the game after this black hat c3 which
is strong it dislodges the night it has
to take now and then black now takes on
f3 and ultimately go to that end game
yeah and that end game is a technical
win for black if he is precise and
karana did a very good job actually up
to a certain point we can fast forward a
little bit check check to that rook
ending here and this is the critical
position in this position he now makes a
mistake he's down to three minutes but
unfortunately for him now he took on a
stream and after that it seems to be a
draw the move that was winning was Luke
a three yeah going over to keep that
pawn and check and March the march de
porn and here the winners looking
relatively simple once you know that
that is their look a 8 for example and
now III and white has very little that
you can do if he goes here we just march
the pawn up black is threatening III
rookie 3 so something like answer here
here check check check check yeah and
something like a 5 e 2 now we have kinky
one you it just it just winds so it's
not quite clear what he overlooked but
he took one age three and now it seems
that giri has the draw yeah the a porn
is coming forward
and black has no particular way to make
his porn County this is what happens
they they gave him a couple of checks
and yeah what is black supposed to do
him you cannot move the rook away from
the a file if he plays age too there's
root age 8 and yeah here I mean white is
threatening to promote like that so
black is starting to give checks it's
certainly an disappointment uniform for
carwin I could have had three
three-and-a-half out of four fantastic
squad um but ultimately didn't manage to
win that very promising rook endgame
yeah and still not a good event for
Geary he struggled in this game most of
the time fighting for equality more than
more than anything else um okay so let's
look at the next game and that game is a
lien off then really here I mostly focus
on a particular situation um we had this
opening and we had the same thing in the
in the soul ding Liren game here early
enough plays with 95 something that I
had mentioned earlier 95 and a possible
f form this is especially effective in
cases where a black Bishop is on d6 so
that a black has a hard time to take the
night in the first place here with the
bishop on e 7 quite often black can play
just with the capture which didn't
happen but we got this kind of structure
quite interesting like TCM for this is a
funny technical sequence by the way ctx
i mean white can also just recapture
there's nothing particularly wrong with
it but you played Knight takes e4
it's really a funny funny sequence if
black now cheeks on me for then Luke
takes d4 is happening quite interesting
with that pin now and sorry the bishop
on your for as hang and yeah that's not
very comfortable in the game when really
took here and now ft xe5 is played they
are quite funny white now wants to take
with the porn here and if he would be
able to would be fantastic so black
should take what you did and rook takes
and we have a double attack on Queen and
Bishop so Bishop had to go to d5 and why
does some taking this piece back now
Bishop c5 is good to know black tix so
in this position one thing is pretty
clear that d5 pawn will get lost you
know there is too much pressure on it
but after the pawn gets lost black is a
pawn down but what we have to see us we
can play a couple of new moves that what
we have to see is that this structure is
not that brilliant for white the bishop
is looking at its own pawn the pawns are
doubled in the first place so it's not
really yeah it's not a completely
valuable extra pond and especially
problematic is that as I said the bishop
is not good on between black he has to
do mainly one thing make sure that II
six is never happening this kind of move
after which white would really be up a
full porn that same and yeah the thing
is after a bishop h4 here black hands
and not counter play the bishop is on
the Rue comes to see to all this is a
fatty fairly harmless let's say as long
as black is avoiding the e6 move as I
said after King edge one now he should
probably play just a waiting
something like green g6 now just stay
basically shuffling and it's not clear
what wide is supposed to do and he
cannot easily move the Queen away sg2 is
attacked and you don't have a clear way
volunteer I think the likelihood of the
draw is pretty high in this some in this
case when video ever made a mistake you
played the Moog f2 and if you like we
can make a little exercise all of that
and try to find the best move now and
try to calculate the whole variation I
think that the first move of it is
probably quite obvious but seeing all of
it is still quite interesting I'll give
you a couple of seconds to pause the
video and figure it out yeah white
played eform yeah this is fairly obvious
then we attack then the Queen and the
rook and the only way for black is to
check on to handle it is checking first
thing that you think is ok if white
takes ok what about this is this
dangerous here black with Queenie one
even has a winning position amazingly
enough so what is the big problem the
problem is this move white is blocking
and now queen is still hanging it had to
move went to f2 and take stakes and now
is 6 as possible so when very allowed
that mentioned dreaded e6 advance that
now gives a white a full upon and the
problem is a little bit that while is
also active in the in the whole process
after taking Queen takes which is what
black should have done and he is really
yeah a lot better now like goes here we
have the possibility to go into that
Bishop ending which is probably a
complete winner I think so black spawns
I even barely placed on a 7 and p6 yeah
white white will
in this very likely yeah what he did is
and played Bishop e7 after 27 it got
chair maybe even worse as another porn
got lost on a seven it's it's this is
debatable both is very very bad but this
was now resigned able and invent Billy
absolutely and I resigned the game yeah
a bit of a shame he had a good event up
to this point with three drawers and he
was even better in one of the games
against Mammadyarov could could one
would have won at one point and and he
actually should have held the draw
against an alien off but um wasn't
precise enough there with the time
ticking down often this is the issue you
are somewhat worse the whole game would
have to be may I have to be precise and
then when the clock ticks down there's
often this one little mistake a big
mistake in this case that costs a whole
game yeah so bit of a shame earphone for
the local guy next game to check is
kayaking too much f ski and somewhat
surprisingly they played an Italian game
not one of kayakers regular openings
sometimes place that but normally he
goes for for the ruler pairs of course
um yeah Tomashevsky plays a classically
with Bishop c5 Knight f6 and we have
this typical main line of them or the
Italian night BD two white has many many
move orders here this is this is one of
them C 3 and a 5 yeah played after some
long thought and I have to say that I
don't like that that kind of structure
that Tomashevsky is going for much I'm
much more of a fan of a 6 h-6 this kind
of thing you know play play like this
this and Bishop b6 well I'm not saying
that a 5 is bad it's just that I don't I
don't really see the point I see that
you prevent before but I think you
weaken your queen side a little bit more
than than necessary in the game h3b
should be six rookie one was played and
they were taking time they were really
playing this over the board that was a
lot part of some preparation um here I
actually thought that black maybe should
take on c4 and simplify the position a
little bit I think this is one of the
points of bishop e6 he didn't do that
maybe he felt that after 98 c 4 white
has a slight pool but it's it's nothing
much i think if you play like a four so
it's that said something very dangerous
i think a black it especially in
comparison to the actual game is quite
comfortable he played age six and our
Bishop b5 was was played that Bishop
balsam is avoiding the trade in some
cases here Bishop takes c6 can be an
issue so black ultimately went for
knight to e7 for that c6 and queen and
night to g6 that we're grouping but the
problem is a little bit that here I feel
that this structure is reached under
somewhat unfavorable circumstances Black
has played a five it has the bishop on
that a seven square instead of c7 let's
say the way it went in this position
here really is uncomfortable for black
there's no doubt they are that I think
white has a slight advantage and the way
it went yet Bishop be area this is
another move way I'm kind of hmm unsure
do you have to do that was it possible
maybe to play more actively with b5 that
allows a form um at position is somewhat
passive it really is somewhat passive I
think and I have to say it's in
bit unclear to me where the I mean I
don't like black set up in general with
a 5 and so on but um I have a hard time
to pinpoint what the actual mistake is
because the position here that they get
if we look at this here this is really
awkward for black yeah White's centers
fantastically supported is super
harmonious yeah those pieces here I
light up so nicely and black has a hard
time to move any of his pawns he cannot
really get d5 in taking on d4 it's
difficult sorry c5 is difficult to do
yeah I don't know black is basically
sitting around yeah with success see
form Bishop c8 and white why just expand
with before and so on and black is in
danger of getting crushed yeah he took
on d form which is yeah ultimately not
helping but if you sit down I mean white
has tons of moves before c5 g5 in a good
moment yeah it just looks like an
excellent version of an old Indian
defense wear black has played the most
passive setup possible that same yeah he
took and tried this but when we see how
comfortable widest service is slowly
improving with be 4n and black now tribe
t5 they both didn't have any time left
yet spending lots of time in the earlier
process and after d5 the game is
definitely um yeah definitely over
whites now place he 5 and black has no
good reply if he goes back with his
night let's say here then why it has
this simple line which will win a pond
with
yeah with the disaster simply nine th
for is also coming that's even the
bigger problem I mean something like
this is just downright awful so we had
to jump into e4 but we already see that
this you for pawned will get lost Bishop
c5 tempo and tiered is gone and white by
this winning um after these moves here
um after to my chefs he took on d6 he
resigned the game before awaiting
further procedures I think he also might
have lost some time I don't know it
doesn't really um appear here on the ICC
interface he's also just lost her if
white takes rook takes and Queen III
this night we get lost black and cover
it for one move but after the further
attack it's over yeah very nice win for
kayaking but um a little bit difficult
to be honest for me to pinpoint what
Tomashevsky is a mistake really was yeah
I moves like d5 p.m. of course they
accelerated the demise but his position
was really bad and out of the opening I
think I mean this this kind of position
here should be absolutely avoided
because it's totally one-sided and
absolutely passive um it's um it's not
clear to me as I said I don't like his
set up there with a 5 and so on but it
ultimately shouldn't be so bad that it
yeah that it loses the game however the
way it went it was a very smooth win for
kayaking okay the last game and to my
mind the most the nicest game of the
round was played here between who you
fond and David navara we got a chiro
khan and the advanced variation the
modern main line of the caro-kann on the
top level you almost exclusively see the
advanced nowadays and it also can be
recommended for play on all levels it
did
it just leads to interesting games and
it's far more dangerous than was
originally thought let's say like 30
years ago okay Bishop f5 and who you
find goes for the the short system the
simple development system let's say that
proved to be one of the toughest nuts
form black to Craig he's going for what
is seems to be quite popular the set up
with 92 age six and nine to f5 however
well I'm not an expert on this opening
but the way it went in this game I have
to admit that I didn't like blacks
position at all yeah we found played
Bishop t2 that looks a bit mysterious
very smallish looking move but it has a
clear point white wants to play the
booth g-form at some at some point in
the game wants to attack the the night
and right away this is a mistake because
black is happy to jump into age four and
after this the black queen is a very
unwelcome visitor here on the Queen sir
on the kingside White's king is weak and
yeah he or she would have huge problems
to keep this yeah keep the z bay I mean
especially considering that white wood
would like to play this you don't want
the queen or age 44 that so this is
plate and now after Bishop e7 only now
and g4s is played so after this sequence
now f4 as possible without the black
queen being on edge for harassing
White's king yeah and I said I don't
like blacks position it's the only thing
I can say for sure Navarro plate f 5m
and it seems to be that this is has been
played before um c for gaining even more
space
and now in this a five yeah and the
problem is a little bit for black that
white is playing on the flank but he
doesn't have any clear counter play in
the center yeah for example if you try
to open the center here after Bishop
takes yeah white is happy about that the
e6 born is very weak and you probably
didn't gain much from that then you also
sometimes see a knight a five queen bee
three to increase the pressure on those
pawns this is often a problem in the
advanced calc on the bishop is outside
of the pawn chain compared to the French
but there are some weaknesses on the
light squares on the queenside yeah he
played a five here gaining some space on
the on the queenside and why'd you stop
that yeah and now I felt like well maybe
black has to take on g4 to avoid what
happens in the game but this also
doesn't seem so great white can trade
and play Bishop takes and well this is
hanging and you cannot easily yeah
easily coordinate your pieces after
Queen B 6 there's this strong move it's
just a waiting move in some way but also
sometimes gets in Queens you form if
black now castles then white can take on
a 5 all of the sudden because group
takes Knight takes Queen takes just
Bishop e6 and wide we'll grab material
next yeah or alternatively this is even
worse yeah it seems that black cannot
really take on g4 without any problems
and that then leads to the conclusion
that castles is right but after g5
blacks position doesn't inspire much
confidence he has to play some age six
sooner or later and he did so now
otherwise that bishop is completely
separated from the rest
of whites army and she would probably
make some regrouping to a Tekkit so I
think age six is more or less yeah
almost forced yeah now she cleared the G
file for the rook very logical White has
more space and has an easier it's easier
for white to use the files because you
have the additional space also note that
legs pieces are not very well placed the
bishop on g6 it's not particularly great
the night on d7 doesn't look great and
the move b6 while again looks a little
bit strange why would you beacon the c6
square yes but there's always some
annoying pressure on a 5 so black maybe
wanted to move the Queen at some point
and this b6 was supporting that idea and
good bite has a direct way to try to
make use of that weaken square and she
went for that rook c6 just attacking e6
and navara now and he decided on all
this right quite quickly i was playing
the game quite quickly just ignored the
attack on the e6 porn however it seems
that white gets an excellent game after
taking it's difficult though to give
black any advice at this point if he
covers the istick spawn then after some
some simple moves let's say like Quincy
two or so what ya controls to see file
and I think can be quite happy what-what
she's got now yeah ok he basically said
ok show me what is your idea ok she took
the pawn bishop f7 rook has to go to the
six Bishop e7 and the rook is strapped
know the route cannot save itself but
she had prepared a fantastic reply just
Bishop to d3 ignoring that rook black
has no choice has to take that check
Bishop f5
came back and now the big point the
point is not to take the bishop back
yeah if white is taking this back then
after Luke c6 it's impossible for white
to keep that pawn a tier black is okay
the rukon d6 is also nicely then
covering age six the point was Quincy
form and this was a really nice job we
are seeing how good this position is why
it is a look down for two pawns at the
moment but is attacking d6 d7 and yeah
sometimes e six is an idea so black has
a hard time to save save his pieces he
tried worked to c7 here the best defense
according to her to the engines is night
to have six a very strange move kind of
a self fork but it seemed to be it
seemed to be better after Queen age 3
however wide also is better something
like this h5 takes t6 now we'll look
move to c4 to be eight and in both cases
there's 27 coming and why its position
is excellent down the compensation that
she's got here for the exchange is more
than sufficient so it's probably better
than this I think after Luke c7 black is
probably not able to to hold it Queen x3
but note how precisely who your phone is
playing this their first threatening the
midday on age six made into now taking
black had to go here and now Bishop e6
also nice to prepare f5 so that after f5
the white Bishop can join the action and
this is what happened here we come black
now grab on d6 which invites Bishop
afforable tempo but if you don't take on
the six white will play Bishop f4 if I
anyway and the issue is that
this kind of position black is
completely tied down cannot move
anything anything active and white some
just want to watch just wants to
activate this night that's the only
piece not doing much here and if it
joins the action it will be game over
this is what happened in the game Bishop
gan now I got this and now the night is
coming d 3 f 4g six Chan here we come
and it's it sure it's just two points
for the exchange but look at the white
white pieces especially that Bishop only
five is monstrous yeah here here 96 is
the threat and this this happened yeah
now we see and this is hanging this is
hanging was check after this kingi to
Navarro reside so yeah he am I think
also was suffering stood a little bit
from this misstep that happened in round
three against Giri but a great effort
here by the former women world champion
who you found and still by far the best
female player and she's got that world
championship match coming up I think
it's in march against maria musa choke
and would be very surprised if she
wouldn't win this match very clear him
we see that he he sorry that she even
sometimes happens so um that she has no
problem at all to compete with players
on the 2700 level especially if she's
getting good positions out of the
opening this is often a problem her
opening prep is not up to the standard
of two thousand seven hundred fifty or
so but if she gets good positions no
problem at all and we see here how
nicely she she managed to win against
David Namara
this means we file is on +1 very good
result after four rounds she didn't have
any issues in the games was very
confidently playing playing those
drawers and now this nice win yeah this
was coverage of round four round five is
played on on Thursday the 21st so there
is a rest day on Wednesday I'll be of
course back again for covering round 5s
and and so on until then have a good
time thanks for watching